-Our next guest is
a legendary television executive
whose memoir "From Saturday
Night to Sunday Night:
My Forty Years of Laughter,
Tears and Touchdowns in TV"
is available now.
Please welcome to the show
the one, the only
Dick Ebersol, everyone.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Dick, I am so happy to have you
here in 30 Rock,
on the eighth floor,
right down the hall
from "SNL" and studio 8H.
You were present at the creation
of "SNL" and then you took over
the show for five years
after Lorne left for a bit.
And you were there
for Eddie Murphy
and Billy Crystal
and Martin Short.
Is it weird to be
back in the building?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It is. It is.
I mean, I drove over here
from our apartment in New York
with my wife and my son,
Charlie.
And I was flashing back to the
first time
that Susan, my wife -- Susan
St. James, hosted the show.
And she was holding Charlie
in her arms.
He had just been born.
[ Audience aws ]
Yeah. You know, that worked
so well for me that, you know,
Seth's been doing that
for years now.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
You talk about and tell a story
in the book
that I'd heard from
the other perspective.
I've heard this story
from Larry David.
It's a famous story,
true to him,
that inspired an episode of
"Seinfeld."
But you can verify the story
about when Larry David quit
"SNL."
-Well, there's no question that
Larry, over the past 40 years,
is one of the top TV comedy
writers of his time.
But he'd hit a time of, uh,
not being on top of his game.
[ Laughter ]
And he was a writer/performer
on "Saturday Night Live."
And he'd gone two or three weeks
without getting a sketch
on the show.
And that's tough when you're
a writer/performer,
if your sketches aren't
getting on the show.
I was the producer and I was
the one who was judging
that I didn't think those pieces
would work on the air.
And so, at the end of one show,
and I did not witness it --
I'm sure there are
plenty of people that think
that's B.S., but I didn't --
and he apparently really let me
have it,
as they were leaving the floor.
And on Monday, when they had --
Monday or Tuesday,
when they had the writers
meeting in my office,
there was, again,
a lot of tittering.
And I turned to our wonderful
British associate producer,
and I said,
"Audrey, what's going on?"
She said, "Well, he got
pretty angry with you
at the end of the show
the other night."
And I said, "What?"
And she said, "Well, he really
let you have it.
You know, accused you
of all kinds of things
for not putting his pieces
on the air."
So I realized that he needed to
find some way out of this,
even though he had yet
to come to my office
and try to have a conversation.
But what had happened was
he'd quit the show.
And his friends were frantic,
trying to get ahold of him
to tell him, "Wherever you are,
go find Dick and apologize
so you can get back on the air.
You don't even have
a health plan, for God's sake."
[ Laughter ]
-It is very funny that he quit
and then just came back to work
the next Monday.
[ Laughter ]
-Right. Right.
-And hoped you wouldn't notice.
And it seems like
you almost didn't.
[ Laughter ]
-It worked out, and I like to
think it proves that
I'm a forgiving human being.
-Yeah, I think so too.
[ Laughter ]
The other incredible thing
because you transitioned
out of comedy
almost directly into sports.
You have an incredible recall
for details in this book.
One moment that you talk about,
the best,
the highlight of your career,
in many ways, was
when you arranged
to have Muhammad Ali
light the Olympic torch.
Can you tell us about that?
-Yeah.
It's the favorite moment
of my entire career.
Comedy, sports, you name it.
My singular moment, for me
at least, was convincing
the Atlanta organizing
committee, who when I first
told them I thought that Ali
should light the caldron,
and I was in the position
to do that.
I had made the television rights
deal down there
for hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds
and hundreds of millions
of dollars.
So I figured, you know,
they'd think this was fine.
And they said to me,
"No, no, he's a draft dodger."
And I just about blew up
at them.
I said,
"What are you talking about?
He was not a draft dodger.
He was a man of great moral
courage who stood on that.
Stood on that."
[ Cheers and applause ]
He gave up so much money and he
went through a lot of hell
in dealing with the government.
But the irony is he was judged
by the United States
Supreme Court
to be innocent 8-0.
And it was
a very conservative court.
So he was totally allowed then
to resume his career,
no thanks to the Atlanta
organizing committee.
But a couple of years ago,
I heard one of those members
of the Atlanta organizing
committee say that,
"You know, it's too bad
what he had to go through."
And I said, "Too bad?
You're the ones who put him
through it."
[ Laughter ]
Anyway, a couple days after -- a
week after the games were over,
I got a phone call
from his now-widow, Lonnie Ali.
And she said, "I'm standing
outside of a building"
at a famous golf course in
Atlanta where they were playing
some championship event.
And you heard
all this chanting and yelling.
And she said, "Dick, I just want
you to hear this
because this is what kept him
out of the public eye.
He was too embarrassed to put
himself out there, thinking that
people would boo him or not like
him or something like that.
And you and your team gave him
back his life."
And I started -- The tears
started to run down my cheek.
And I thought of how much
he'd missed out on, and now,
when I think about it
afterwards,
he didn't feel that way.
-Well, that's a pretty great
best moment in television.
I think very few measure
up to that.
You also talk/write quite
beautifully about tragedy.
You lost your son Teddy
when he was 14 years old
in a plane crash.
Did you find -- and you write,
again, very sweetly about
what a full life you had,
how happy you were
to have 14 years with him.
Was this more
for your own catharsis?
Or were you trying to give this
as a gift
to other parents
when you wrote about that?
-I think the latter.
I find as a parent, my wife
obviously was part of this.
She bore him.
But we felt so fortunate to have
had him for so long,
and we tell people now,
when we're asked to speak
or whatever, we think
it's really important within
your own family, grandchildren,
senior grandchildren,
you name it, for them
to really know that kid.
And in our family, it's amazing
where there's I think 14 or 15
grandchildren,
ranging down to ages like 1, 2,
3, up to age 14,
and they talk about him.
They talk about him
as if they knew him
because they've heard
all the stories.
And that is cathartic.
I mean, it really means that
you don't have to give up
on somebody who is such a part
of your life just because
they physically aren't there
anymore.
There are memories to be
cherished forever
and to be discussed forever.
And I can't emphasize enough to
families who are going through
this today or have already,
talk about it.
It's so important to keep
those spirits alive.
-Well, it's a wonderful message.
It's a wonderful book.
And just thank you so much
for being here.
It feels very fitting to have
you back at 30 Rock.
Thank you so much.
Dick Ebersol, everybody.
-Thank you, Seth, very much.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-"From Saturday Night
to Sunday Night"
is available now
wherever books are sold.
But please support your local
and independent bookstores.
We'll be right back.